now i'm not saying every woman is meant
to be a mom i'm not there are women out
there i think you have to know yourself
i think you really have to if you know i
don't want children no matter what and
you've dated maybe you don't want
children maybe right but i will say this
i got to 37 years old 37 i met my i did
not want children i was like this isn't
for me i just don't think it's what
percentage of women want children what
percentage of men want children since
we're doing stuff yeah i got legitimate
right though you didn't do that stat
about how women are happier without
procreating getting married i don't know
one woman i'm gonna be honest with you
one watching how women are happy women
are happier without procreating not me i
lie i've enjoyed this experience that i
did with my children but look at this
both stats yeah i'm also curious like
how do we know that which was they say
they're happier because i don't know one
woman
that gets to that age how do you know
because oh by the way jackpot how the
hell was that woman
she never had kids yeah that's another
thing i'm thinking when you kept saying
that when you kept saying like how do
people know that they don't want to have
children like how can they so that's
that's did you know that i don't know if
that status [ __ ] but it doesn't need
to lose it you know what i think
you need more than that is create a
sample for me though for me i met
someone who i i think often times what
happens is these women get so buried in
their career they're not open right
they're not thinking about relationships
they're like this is i'm a badass i'm a
career woman their eyes aren't looking
around they're not dating they're not
making time for that and as a result
they don't have a chance to meet that
partner that really makes them think
differently i met my husband at 37 i had
never won a kid before i looked at him i
said
wow i want to have this man's kid i want
to have a baby with this guy this is
something special this is this man's kid
well yeah but it's mine too it's mine
i'm telling you about the language
girlfriend i highlighted the language
hyphenated maybe you know
i feel like through this career i left
myself open and you have to leave
yourself open if you just bury your head
down in your career and you're not open
you're not going to find that guy and
you may miss out women need to know that
that it's a very empowering experience
to have a child and to bring a human
problem as you can should be a mom you
can't give it back you can't be like let
me give this a [ __ ] try oh [ __ ]
made the wrong decision for the rest of
my life
it's a keeper adam there was an article
recently that came out where there were
a bunch of women that said i wish i
hadn't had a child oh my god i had a
child and i wish i i got to tell you
though i read these articles i don't
know one person that has a baby that
doesn't that that says that they do i
don't know one they always say you know
what i love this child i don't know any
of those women no we should bring them
on i want to talk to them
i'll help you know about women that what
yeah i know about many women who regret
um having children
they regret it do they regret having
children i regret having children with
them without
having drawing their careers
it wasn't even about throwing their
careers away i i am a mother mother i i
i i don't know i'm a mother mother so
i've enjoyed the experience that i've
had with my children there is not one
day that i regret bringing them to this
world at all but do i meet women that
oftentimes look at me many many many
that look at me and they say shauni how
do you do this there's something wrong
with it
whatever it is sometimes they're married
sometimes they're not sometimes in and
often times depending on what type of
child i don't think we are really
looking at just how
um demanding being a mother is that
cannot be misrepresented and not all
people um can really give of themselves
in that way
yeah she's working there's a there's
somebody we threw at her that you're
never gonna know cause they feel so
guilty telling you they regret it it's
true but people tell me they think
you're never gonna know okay let me just
tell you a story frame this and we're
gonna move on to the next topic i'm
having dinner with some of my best
friends tonight they're all between the
ages of 30 where we go 42.
feel free to join us i'm 43 sorry i'm
outta here you're out bro
i'm the only single okay there's gonna
be ten guys there they're all married
with kids okay so nine out of ten
married with kids i'm the cool uncle
this is part of the reason i don't need
kids right now is because i've got
20 nieces and nephews that i can just
hang out with anytime i want my best
friends that's not the same
i'm talking about myself i know okay i'm
talking about them yeah every single one
of them
when i asked because i asked them these
questions
how you like having kids like bro it's
so [ __ ] hard you have no idea how
hard it is be ready like dude take your
time don't rush into this oh my god the
kid with the bills yeah do you regret it
not at all
not at all so that tells me yeah it's
hard
yeah it sucks yeah nobody wants to
change diapers yeah nobody wants to
chase kids around yeah you don't hate
carpool but at the end of the day it's
worth it that's exactly what jedediah
said okay
and i'm gonna tell you that don't that
regret having children and i speak
i'm not going to undermine that there
are many women that have created
children
of women
90 of women are happy that i will
guarantee you
it i'm not one of those women but you
seem to share a lot of stats that are
just like
they're they're just off they're just
awful they're not my stuff no they're
just wake up and make them stack yes you
do and you and they're to the left too
well they don't even support it i'm with
you but they found out that i make up
the only one
even the one the stat that you were
talking about 25 to 50 percent of what
you know 45 percent yeah but you're not
even you're looking for
something you don't look at the other
what's the other side the other side
that a lot of women are living happily
happy without creating children and
without getting no no no no no no no no
no no i'm sure they're happy so when you
ask what are they going to be doing with
their 52 years as if they happen
but how would they know we have a case
example right here
happy with her career but when she's
happier
having kids i guarantee if you're a
woman and you come out and you say i
regret it i guarantee you there's going
to be the reasons that are going to be
cited if you really dig into it it's
going to be money there's not enough
money it's going to be there's a problem
in that relationship it's going to be
that you don't feel supported you're
carrying the weight of the bird you know
some dads their stories out there
that got killed yeah you were or you
just don't have there's a support system
that's lacking there when you're when
you have children it's very important
for for mom and dad to be involved they
have to be they but those kids need both
parents if that situation is such that
dad is off working all the time and now
mom who wasn't sure if she wanted kids
has kids and she's 100 in the home she
may be miserable that is a fact but if
that were a different type of
relationship and she had support i don't
think that's the way that conversation
would go so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
[Music]